hi I'm Jason Harris I work in the front
end and I'll be talking about the native
Wolfram player for iOS
okay well it's rolled round to ten
o'clock I'm sure we'll get some
stragglers then but I might as well kick
things off so for the people here just
go to the the passable website and write
there and download the The Notebook here
you can see it here just click on that
and get the workshop notebook okay so
welcome to this workshop on advanced
typesetting so in this talk I'm going to
detail some of the capabilities the
advanced typesetting capabilities of
Mathematica and what do we mean by
typesetting well of course it's always
nice to you know X superscript 2 and we
can position the two very nicely or the
fraction nicely or something but as
Steven talked about we like computer
computational essays we like to be able
to present a whole flow of a narrative
and to do that we need to be able to
introduce our own notations for for our
own concepts that are not actually built
right into Mathematica and so we want to
have a nice essay or in a nice
presentation of the normal concepts you
use from physics math chemistry computer
science biology whatever that isn't
actually built in and so the whole point
of this workshop is to show you what we
do internally so you can do the same
things that we do internally to extend
Mathematica it's it's and so we're not
just so much interested in like a tech
presentation or typesetting we want to
be able to do computation with it we're
Mathematica
so we're Wolfram so so in this in this
presentation I'll explore ways in which
you can create your own notations for
your particular field of study and to do
that we need to talk about what lies
underneath the front end what language
does the front end talk and as it talks
between the front end and the kernel the
front end talks boxes the kernel talks
expressions and so we need to be able to
go back and forth there's a rich API in
there that we can we can target we can
change and an effect change in how the
the front-end and the kernel talk to
each other to introduce our own
notations and so you can have nice
presentations so that's through make
boxes and make expressions the front-end
talks boxes underneath just just like is
it a web page if we go to this
particular web page and I go here and I
take a look at and Safari I go show the
web inspector you'll see of course a web
page talks you know divs and
paragraphs and everything else the front
end actually talks boxes and so we need
to talk about boxes the the
correspondence that the translation
between the front and the kernel and
doing that then through that we'll work
our way up to template boxes and discuss
about style sheets okay and during the
course of this presentation we'll
briefly touch on the notation package
which simplifies the creation of these
make boxes and make make expression
rules and and so on
okay so what's our goal let's let's just
sort of state it here in a normal sort
of input I can you know escape that get
a partial derivative and get that with
respect to X of you know X cubed and
Mathematica understands that just fine
of course but what happens if we come in
here and we change this you know that
partial there to a plus Mathematica
doesn't understand it so our goal is
basically to be able to extend
Mathematica so we can understand this we
extend it in the same way that we do
internally so Mathematica will do
computations with this and so of course
we can represent our operators from
whatever field that we're working in and
so of course it's not just to define
partial plus but it's to do things like
partial plus for for other other sorts
of operations and so that's our goal so
to do that we have to understand what
lies beneath what how does Mathematica
that how does the front end work with
very stuff so here we have some
expression and so right up here there's
a cell there's a show expression so if
you if you I'll just call it command
shift D throughout this presentation so
if you command shift E on on a
particular cell you'll see what's
actually underneath there and so you can
see this X cubed that actually
corresponds in the Mathematica Box
language to this superscript box of X
comma 3 and there's a row box grouping
all of this together and in fact we
could come around here and we can
actually change that to a 5 for instance
and then you know command shift e again
to get back to the cell and of course
we've changed the actual input so so the
the the boxes can be edited directly in
a sort of the underlying form or more
traditionally of course we just edit
things in our our particular editor and
change it here so likewise if we take a
look at this particular integral and now
I hit command
shifty again that's the cell show
expression command 15 will see this
underlying form so this integral here
that's the integral that's the base of
this sub superscript box there's the
zero which is the under script there's
the infinity which is the over script
there the upper script
there's the superscript box here and
then we see there's an exponential a
there's a row box here for this this top
bit here and then there's a superscript
box for the XZ and there's a
differential D and so on and then of
course we could as before go in and
change something here change the
underlying form and and evaluate and it
it all sorts of works it's a box and in
fact let me just show you just how much
is actually boxes so let's let's let's
just show you what goes on in the under
line form so in your notebook if you
evaluate this this is just an input
field with continuous action goes to
true and we've got this dynamic of the
boxes and that's linked here and we can
just see the output and so here is I
actually type a plus B you can actually
see that row box underneath and so this
is this is an example of sort of what
the editors doing underneath this is how
the the whole thing works underneath and
so if I type in this integral here
you're gonna see that's just first the
base character I hit the control the
under script to get to the to the the
under script there and it's we see it's
a subscript box all that control percent
to get to the sub super script box type
in the Infinity and then type in here
the exponential e and you can see it's I
type all of the various bits here on the
the in this input field are being
created as I type the expression so
really what happens in the front end is
that we have a box editor and so as we
type there's all these boxes getting
pars and recreated and formatted and so
I'm responsible along with John for the
box editor and in the front end and so I
wanted you just as your first exercise
really simple enter a plus B times C and
that input field in your notebook and
see what happens
and we see it's actually pre Lexton sort
of pre pars that's actually grouped
according to the precedents x has a
higher precedence than plus and so we've
grouped the rope the row box is tighter
around the one particular operator now I
could actually enter in a plus here and
you'll see that that the front end box
editor can actually handle that it of
course it gives us a box structure you
can enter this into some particular cell
so even though this makes sense to the
front end it doesn't make sense to the
kernel it's not a complete expression so
if I try and enter that the kernel will
reject those boxes but it'll accept
those so the front end has to accept
more more boxes than than the kernel
okay so getting back to your question
there of what is an actual box you might
say well okay that's so that all your
normal typesetting your math is as boxes
but graphics it surely that's lines and
you know other things well that graphics
is actually a graphics box of wine boxes
and so you might think wow okay that's
maybe for wise but what about you know
complex things like Bay's ei curves and
some of the other bits well underneath
it's actually a Bezier curve box of wine
boxes and point boxes so it turns out
that all graphics are actually boxes and
you might say well okay so graphics and
and and masses is our boxes but what
about things in a style you know we're
gonna build a notebook programming here
but that turns out to be a style box a
button if we enter that you know we can
click on it does stuff we take a look
that's actually a button box a slider
here we're connecting here this variable
MN through this dynamic here and so as I
move the the the value of the slider and
discrete steps of one we see this the
Specter station well that slider itself
is a slider box underneath and the
dynamic is a dynamic box so it's all
about boxes everything is a box in
Mathematica that we we in the front end
and it's it's representation so and so I
together with some of the other my
colleagues are in charge of the boxes
and and in the front end okay so given
that everything's a box we in the front
end but it's an expression in the kernel
we need the front end and the kernel to
be able to talk to each other so what
happens so I get some expression like
this I
you ate it and so we'd get some nice
partial derivative sine Y over two we
get its answer what actually happened so
what we see is it starts off with the
box structure that gets changed through
it gets parsed through into a kernel
expression that currently that kernel
expression gets evaluated to a new
kernel expression that gets formatted to
a new box structure so it's sort of like
this if I get this input here and we
start off in the front end with these
boxes this subscript box of partial d
the fraction box have sine Y over to
this row box and so on and that's sort
of then that gets translated through
parsing to a sort of an expression a bit
more like that that you can actually
sort of think of and so that gets
changed into this particular form and
the now and this D sine Y over to that
that form there gets evaluated that that
expression then gets evaluated in the
kernel to this particular form here and
that form in the kernel then gets sent
back to the front end through formatting
and we get these boxes so we start off
with these boxes that the front end sees
that gets translated to this expression
through make expression it's it gets
parsed right up here and then that gets
evaluated in the kernel to something
like this and that gets sent back to the
front end through make boxes to that
kind of expression and so that's how we
receive we perceive the evaluation to
occur it goes straight from the box
structure to a new box structure that we
see but it's going and doing this sort
of loop this diagram chasing so how does
how does that help us well it helps us
if we can change the parsing and change
the formatting we can control what
Mathematica does and so that is the next
step so one of the things you should
probably do is take a look at the make
boxes documentation here open this up
for later on and you'll see down at the
bottom here there's this low-level input
and output rules and there's some
example later on that you might want to
sort of follow that sort of pairs up
with with with this with this talk okay
so let's go now and change some stuff so
let's get back to our example that we
motivate enos this partial plus of
right now Mathematica doesn't understand
it we want Mathematica to be able to
understand it so what happens well it
can't parse this expression so we we can
see here which expression can't it parse
I'm using command shift B here to
balance it so I can I can select the
whole a whole box structure there so I'm
getting this whole row box here and now
so it's make expression of this right
now
in standard form and Mathematica can't
do it it doesn't know the answer to that
so to make this actually work we need to
tell Mathematica what the answer to this
is and so we're gonna actually have to
tell it what's that answer
well Mathematica does know how to we'll
call it pd+ that'll be our full internal
form of this particular operator and
Mathematica can make that it can do it
so like I can go here and I can grab the
boxes for that here like so and now I
can do make expression make expression
of those particular boxes in standard
form and it will know the answer so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to say the
answer to this which Mathematica doesn't
know in terms of the answer for
something it does know like so and now
if I evaluate this particular input it
understands it right so we've got
parsing that's great but of course this
isn't fully general yet because if I
come in here and I change that to like a
Q Mathematica doesn't understand it
again so we need to change this rule
here to make that a general T for
instance and we put the T here and now
we have the general rule and so I can
you know it understands that it'll
understand this and so on okay so that's
that's parsing that's great but now of
course with any sort of notation if I
enter that I'm not getting the
formatting it doesn't appear in this
nice pd+ that that you'd want it to as
if you understand PD pluses so we need
now a make make boxes rule so this is
now doing that taking an expression two
boxes need to make boxes rule and so of
PD plus PD plus of some tea
in standard form it's going to be cool
what boxes is it going to be well it'll
be these boxes so I go command shifty
again take a look at that box structure
here copy that go here paste it in and
that would actually work so that that's
great we do that right exactly so we
take got a tea there so it's it's you
know if I put a W in here yeah we're
still getting cute so right here I'd
like to put a tea but this is an
expression the stuff the on the on the
left hand side we've got pd+ of tea teas
an expression it needs to be a box and
so if I put that end and I put some you
know W squared right over here it's
going to give some sort of problems
there and if we take a look underneath
we see oh and actually put an expression
in there this cell context and that
needs to be a box so what we need is we
need to make boxes to make boxes make
boxes of tea comment standard form to do
that and now we can get the final result
here and it actually works and we can
take a look at that full form of the
last result and it's PD plus a power
coming too
so what happened here originally when
this rule here wasn't actually a make
boxes on this we have an expression
coming in here and it put an expression
there and so when I when I do that I'm
getting an expression in the box then
the box form up there at the very top
and and so the box it needs to be boxes
it's like you entered text directly in
HTML it has some problems and so we need
to actually make that further argument
here into boxes right so that was an
expression so this is an expression and
it's a box we need it to be right yep
okay so and so the rest of this and in
fact you can evaluate so I won't get you
to type that in just yet but you just go
into your notebook evaluate those things
and now of course we can define rules
for this but here's some you know
partial plus its will make it a linear
operator so we can do that and evaluate
now is the partial plus is the sum of
the partial pluses we could go in here
and put in another rule if we want you
know it's guy PD this guy
subscript plus of let's say Q underscore
^ t is going to be equal to I don't know
yeah T squared Q to the t minus 1 for
instance and now we evaluate that again
and that partial plus of x squared will
evaluate to you know according to our
rules so we can enter expressions and we
can we can now use there are notations
to do to do computations and in
Mathematica and indeed this is pretty
much sort of the stuff we do internally
for all of our you know advanced
typesetting our special functions and
many other things and we'll building up
to to that and of course this has the
correct full form as we want okay so
with that in mind the first oh and I'll
also mention here so one of the other
tricks here so if we've given some
textual form y squared y squared plus RP
d plus of T of T here if I hit this
right here this cell convert to standard
form what it'll do is it'll run through
this make button make expression make
boxes again and we'll get a particular
that will get the the typeset form of
this expression so um it can't do it of
course if it's not a complete expression
so if I just go here and make a plus and
I hit this command shift and it won't
work I get rid of the plus and it will
actually work and I can go command shift
then and it'll it'll change into the
standard form of those boxes I can
select just a small a selection of that
and go command shift N and it'll do that
thing in place and so that'll of course
work even if I have a plus there because
I'm selecting a whole complete
expression so it's quite it's quite
useful to go back and forth using this
cell convert to standard form so so
that's good and of course when I'm doing
this conversion it's very important that
I don't evaluate if there's a two plus
two in here
so if I have a plus two plus two it's
not evaluating the two plus two and so
when it with that sorry it's a bit hard
typing typing standing up here this it's
a keyboards at an odd angle you'll so
you'll see here that we're not doing any
evaluation and so it's very important in
our make boxes and make expression rules
that we don't have evaluation links okay
so your first thing your first exercise
so the this is now a function it's built
into Mathematica this this you can type
this you know a escape FN FN escape of
you know a squared sorry
hey and that you know applied to
something like you mathematicians can
read this even maple users who probably
read it as well and so it works as we
want but and everything in aesthetic is
a first class object so of course this
this function by itself as possible so
your goal is to make this here this this
this this notation for for function be
the dominant way Mathematica will
display that and so we need of course
some make boxes rule for some functions
sort of thing it is going to be in
standard form is going to be what boxes
so we'll put some you know yes there a
there what are the boxes that are going
to go on the side so that's your
exercise create that rule well so of
course here you're wondering what box is
to actually use to put it in there and
so well the trick we always do is we go
and we use the boxes mathmatica casts so
we'd go here grab those boxes we click
on those go to 50 and just go and grab
these particular boxes here so we're
gonna it's gonna be exactly making it up
yourself you're gonna get it wrong what
we always do so you just go grab those
boxes just as I did paste that and so
it's gonna be like this and so that's
good but of course that's we don't have
you know that's Q and that's Q squared
we've got the wrong output here it's
gonna be a so we need to make this
general so I normally put an a here but
of course we've got the same problems
before so that needs to be make boxes
come on make boxes , standard form and
likewise on this superscript box there
change that and change it to an S and
now this particular function well-well
will work and we put this in and so
that's now that the the default form for
for functions we've changed Mathematica
so that the default representation and
standard form of a function of two
arguments is is this nice notation we've
got here okay and and if you want to
take a look the answer is down there and
so you can evaluate it right there and
try it yourself okay so given that is
the first exercise the next exercise is
to create a notation here for up and
down so we have up arrow Mathematica
doesn't understand that of a doesn't
format is that so we need to create make
boxes and make expression rules so that
up of a will will format as the a
superscript heir-apparent and same with
down and you get that character that up
arrow character by its you know this
this slash up in square bracket up arrow
and you know return and same with down
okay
but it slash and then up arrow so you
can do that for it ferment and many of
the other special characters as well so
you know like gamma you know return it
etc okay well at least by now you're
probably thinking about the the right
way to actually do this I'll just go
ahead and I'll show you but at least as
part of the workshop it's like how do I
go about that how do i you know what are
my first steps how do i think about it
so let's let's do the the make
expression rule here so what we want to
do is we want these boxes here we want
Mathematica to be able to understand
that box expression there so make
expression and standard form is going to
be what expression well it's the same as
make expression of this other thing here
which boxes it's gonna be these boxes so
we go here copy those in standard form
and of course we want a general a here
and a general a here and now we've got
the rules for up of a so so we can now
parse up a vein and in the same way we
just copy this previous result here
change this here to down arrow and we
make this down and now we've got you
know plus you know be down arrow here
we've got down to be plus up of a okay
so that's the make expression rules we
need also similarly we need to make
boxes rules because of course we want
this to appear in a nice form so we're
going to now take make boxes what are we
going to make boxes on
of a score and standard form is going to
be which boxes well which box it's going
to be these ones right here so I'll just
get this subscript box there there copy
that I said in and likewise before we
need to make this argument make boxes on
the current argument and standard form
and now this will actually format as we
actually want and so the same way here
with down we now have down arrow so this
is now the complete rules for creating
are up and down arrows to pars and
format they have the correct full form
like so okay
and so those rules are down below here
in the answer okay so you can enter
those and and and run with those okay so
moving on to something a little bit more
complicated try and stick with an
example even if you don't follow all the
details at least you're getting sort of
the flavor of it and you can come see us
later on and and we'll go through the
bits but here's a common question
sometimes we have a list of lists and in
traditional form that appears as a
matrix but in standard form it just
appears as a list of Lists what happens
if we wanted that to appear a bit more
like a matrix what would we do to
actually make this make this appear like
a a matrix so well we've got the
internal form we're not trying to change
how things pars because of course when I
enter this it parses a list of Lists it
knows that so this is a make boxes role
here
what boxes is the front end going to
have for some sort of list of something
else like this it's gonna be and you
know standard form here is going to be
some set of boxes which boxes should be
actually used well it should be the same
boxes as this kind of thing here we go
here take a look at there's there's a
you know form box here of the stuff go
here and grab that row box of the whole
thing copy that go here paste this in
well paste it I'll just paste it here
and we've got all this other options the
grid blocks alignment we don't want the
grid box space things we don't want and
so we're down to something a bit more
like that so it would have that would
work and would get ya so because
evaluation happens so that's that's okay
but of course we've just got this this
one expression here we want this to be
general not just for two by two so we
put in here something matrix and I'm not
worrying about the evaluation
characteristics right now but and of
course we've got to get this list of
Lists we've got a map in the right place
so if I get that output here and I know
if I put some map of F on the particular
arguments we're not actually mapping at
the right level there we're not wrapping
around each argument so what would want
to do is we want to put a map of F here
at level 2 and so yep that's that's what
we want so we're gonna try and map onto
each of the arguments and we're not
going to map of course we're gonna match
something like make boxes of pure
function then standard form like so okay
so that's that's the kind of thing we
actually want to do so we're just going
to grab this on the output here go here
into this grid box paste that and change
this to a ok and so now as I enter this
particular expression here it looks as
it should e and so on so that that's
grand and so we've got this rule this
make boxes here we've constructed the
boxes we've built this up so it
constructs you know a row box the grid
box and it Maps make boxes onto each of
the arguments that are that are in our
initial matrix and so that's that's the
step that we actually want but we've got
one problem that's evaluation creeps in
here and so here if I go to this input
form right here and I hit command shift
n it's evaluated it's changed that two
plus two into a four and that's because
my make boxes rule here is leaking the
evaluation so evaluation happens and so
I need to stop that so how would I stop
that I'd go here and make sure that's
matrix Q of a but I put here unevaluated
unevaluated
okay
and likewise here I need to make sure
I've got a a here on evaluated of a and
now this pure function here this map
right there I need to make that pure
function unev al you ate it as well so
I'm going to change this to function of
you know F comma make boxes of F that's
the equivalent form and I'll make that
hold all okay now that and I'm gonna go
back here I'm gonna quit my kernel just
so you don't have any other previous
rules and now if I value eight that I go
back here it works as it should and if I
hit command shift n yeah we've got back
to the form it hasn't done extra
evaluation and in that particular step
okay so and that the answers here are
down below with some the correct
handling okay
so that's a bit tricky a bit complicated
but at least you know how it's how it
works how do we make this easier how
does this process how do we make that
easier well we can actually use the
notation package and so here's here's an
example from ring addition and ring
multiplication it doesn't doesn't work
currently in Mathematica it doesn't
understand that so I can hit escape
notation like here and on the outside
right here I'm gonna put some form
that's the box structure form so here I
put you know plus I'm gonna do a
subscript and then escape SC R for the
ring that's a script ring script R for
the ring addition and so in here we put
the full form ring plus of a underscore
comma B underscore and now Mathematica
will understand ring addition and it has
the crate full form
as you'd expect okay so that's great so
so we can actually now I'll just change
that here copy the various bets change
that two times change this to ring times
and now it understands this particular
full thing has the rightful form as
you'd expect
okay so we've extended the Mathematica
now with with the spring plus and
ring-ring addition for stuff that it
didn't actually understand the question
now is how did this actually work so
we're done so what happens that I'll
talk about precedence a little bit later
on but this plus subscript R and the
time subscript R the precedence of that
is the same any scripted operator is the
precedence of the base operator and we
can actually use syntax for them with
tag boxes and stuff to change precedence
and later on but I'll talk about that
towards the end but right now it knows
the precedence of this and in fact it
group this correctly it grouped the
multiplication here like this because
you can actually sort of see this in the
front end as well if you take a look at
the box structure you see this this box
structure is more tightly grouped the a
and the B is actually more tightly
grouped but it comes from that base
precedents of the time so when I type a
times B plus C it groups the the a and
the B together more tightly because the
precedence of x is higher and because
there's a x there we're subscript in it
and it says what's the precedence of a
subscript to think what's the precedence
the base and that's that's how it got it
cool so good question so the question is
where the the issue that's raised of
course is what is the notation package
actually doing how does it work well the
notation package is a transpiler
or a compiler of notation statements and
to make boxes and make expression rules
it builds them for you and so we can
actually take a look if we remove the
notation private sort of stuff and here
it builds it has its own space this
notation to make expression and here you
can sort of see a notation make
expression of this a subscript box of
plus R it
it's that's the kind of thing you'd have
before you'd have a make expression
here's some stuff on the left left hand
side some stuff on the right here and
then finally what are we making it to
well it makes it as make expression of
this ring plus of you know robox of a
common beat pretty much like you'd
create it before likewise the notation
make boxes well that's actually ring
plus but our formatting rules have
already kicked in to format it there
sometimes when you're taking a look at
information you you you think it's ring
plus but it's already actually formatted
but it is ring plus under underneath
them and there's this parenthesize the
notation package does a little bit more
than than our rules and so it
parenthesizes things correctly in fact i
could go here and put you know plus q in
the output and would actually see our
parentheses have been automatically
added to make sure we we get the right
grouping so using this action print
notation rules you can see the rules
that the notation package actually
builds okay so the next question then is
example up and down revisited so this is
an example for you load the notation
package and create a rule for up and
down to pars and format so you know go
here type a notation escape notation
that escape notation we're off indeed
off of the pallet here and then you put
on this form you put a what do you put
on the external bit you're gonna put
some a you put underscore up their own
and you put up okay here and now it'll
understand the thing we're up with cue
or alpha W and so on
okay and the same way with down I should
point out in the notation package we
have under scripts on both sides because
the rule has to work sort of both ways
it needs to pick out which of the
arguments on yep exactly so we can week
with with the right up the top there we
can have just a notation that parses us
or just a notation that formats so in
other words if we if we got this
particular rule here and we changed that
I think we can do this what is it here
grab that go here change this and I'm
going to quit the curl local go here
with the notation package go down here
and just evaluate this then when I hit
up of W we just get it but I get here of
down down
little format so that's just a one-way
sometimes you you want the notation to
only go one way or sometimes you only
wanted to parse sometimes only format
and so on most often it's it's both ways
you want to both pars and format so it's
it's the same in both input and output
right well you so again with symbolize
so then you've got some when you go here
and you symbolize something and you take
a look you can you know symbolize you
know X to the N underscore or something
else like that then you actually take a
look at this this box structure a
template box so you can actually enter
that in yourself so you can
programmatically do it if you do some
make expression some trickiness but you
need to reproduce that box structure so
you can do it programmatically if you
want yep no no no no because that yes no
you need this you need this box
structure around it so because this is
this is a meta thing it's it's a
expression that's parsing boxes and it's
grabbing the boxes and doing it so it
needs a needs to somehow escape and so
it needs a special box structure around
it to to get it to work okay so so
finally one of the other things I want
to mention here is quickly entering
notations one of the bits of the
notation package is you've got this add
input aliases and so we can you know
escape opu escape and that gives us some
sort of up operator here with a you know
cube
whatever yeah we'll we'll be able to
quickly enter some particular template
and of course you know the D and TT for
instance we've got some of these built
into mathematical ready that's a
definite integral one we can you know
tab around all the various bits you can
build your own just by putting it in in
here okay so I'm just going to briefly
mention tag boxes so tag boxes are used
to guide the interpretation we don't use
them so much more as much as we used to
so in version eight I added template
boxes and they've sort of caught on like
wildfire and now all of our sort of
almost all of our typesetting uses them
and I'll get to them just quite shortly
but I should mention here that that we
use them sometimes for things like grid
and so you see this grid box and you say
well you know I thought that was a
list of lists it's a matrix you know why
why is it parsing is you know and when I
take a look the output get the full form
full form of that will you see its grid
how does it know it's a grid and you
know we enter it it still stays is a
grid well it's because there's this tag
box here so the make expression rules
come along and they say well we're gonna
make this oh hey there's a tag box with
this tag grid hey I know what to do I'm
not going to do the normal thing I'm
gonna do the the grid thing and it's a
form it's like it a grid and in fact we
could actually come here and actually
remove this this tag box here turn round
remove it there form a debt and it's a
list of lists so it really understood by
having that tag box in place that
there's different make expression rules
that will go in and identify that that
thing is it is a no I that's because the
built-in rules that we have in
Mathematica so there's this really core
of just boxes mathematic itself when it
loads loads up all these make expression
then make boxes rules and one of those
is just lists of lists it's built really
into low level at the parser why that
now works like that is it because we
don't have the tag box surrounding it if
there was a tag box it says hey I'm not
a list of lists I'm a grid and it kicks
in okay and so we have as well they're
used in like Mouse appearance you know
if we change this to you know food here
you know we get some some different
cursor and that's that's because the
front end recognizes this particular tag
when it's moving over the thing and
adjusts the cursor it'll do it so it's
used in a few other places as well but
we've all moved on to template boxes so
let's actually do that ourselves let's
move on to template boxes these magical
things are really kind of cold so so
here we've got a binomial and comma K
you know by now this is going to be what
are the boxes for this well it's going
to be a grid box with with you know a
bracket bracket you know and over a K
and so let's take a look at those boxes
and it's not it's a template box of n
comma K with binomial bizarre and in
fact if I go in here that binomial I
change that to like bessel J and format
it now looks like a vessel J and if I
evaluate it evaluates like a vessel J so
just changing
tag here if I go in here and you know
Legendre P for instance the P if I've
tied that correctly acts like a loser on
trapeze so right here just this just
this magical tag has telling us what to
what this should look like and also how
it should evaluate which is truly kind
of freaky and kind of cool and so what's
actually going on underneath here so
let's actually just take a look at a
generic the bra boxes just displays the
Box directly in line and so we've got
this template box we've got this this
tag here foolish entre P and this
tooltip so as I move over here I see
this tooltip and that comes up as my
legendre ping I could go in here and
change this here to you know something
else and I see yep indeed that's that's
where it's getting its tooltip from so
that explains this bit here the next bit
here is if I evaluate this I'm getting
foolish and repiy how did it know to do
that well there's this built in like
I'll go in here and I'll change this to
doggy and evaluate that and I get doggy
legendre peace so really it's coming in
here you can see that whatever tag I put
in here is what this thing will evaluate
is so the the default rule for a
template box is just basically get the
that the name of the the template there
and apply it as a head of the arguments
that it's gone now finally the next
question is how does it display like
this well we can go in here and we can
change this to you know like www here
and we see it's changing so this this
function here right here is somehow
affecting the output and it's called
display function so what it actually
does is we get that display function we
apply the arguments to it here of a
comma B and we get a box structure and
if we take a look at that box structure
and look at it raw boxes
it looks like that so the display
function now is telling it how this
thing should display so it would this
this whole the template box contains all
the information through this just this
this name here that's how it should
evaluate this is the tooltip and this
display function here is the thing that
we apply on to these arguments to get a
box structure that will then display as
is the the way that we want the template
box to actually display okay so one of
the other nice things about a template
box here is that it's you can tab
through the various arguments works we
can delete one of the arguments it'll go
to the other argument it'll delete the
whole thing so it really is a templated
structure so let's actually see how this
works and practice so we've got this we
go back to here this binomial and let's
get another binomial here q/t just for
just my sake and so we see here this is
a template box of binomial but we don't
have a display function there where is
the display function coming from well if
a template box this is something quite
fortuitous I built in way back when at
the template box has a string name and
that that's a style so if we go take a
look at the style sheet go here to the
default styles go here to the core
styles and then find binomial we get
down to this we go back here take a look
at the styles for attendees paste it in
the bottom and right right there we can
actually see oh that's a queue binomial
okay we didn't want that we wanted
binomial binomial there we go found it
go here paste that in there and so here
we have this by Neyman let's make that a
bit bigger so we can see it attendees so
here here right here is this binomial
and that if we take a look at that is
going to have a display function
would actually expect so that really now
has a display function of a row box
you know the bracket the grid box and
the closing bracket so that's much more
like what would expect but now let's say
we want to change that and actually give
a give a different display function like
C you know K choose K things out of n
something a bit more like that we could
actually get these box structure here
and if we want this to be a box function
from before so we'll go here we'll
change this to you know hash to here
this B hash one for instance and go here
get that particular box bit here go here
and replace this in our boxes paste and
now when I hit this when I hit this and
I actually unform at it it's going to
change all of the binomial displays to
be this sub super script box of of C so
you're looking here on this bit here the
these binomials and three to one you'll
see the vole changed so uniformly we can
change how a template box in fact all of
our advanced typesetting all of our
standard functions special functions and
stuff are usually done through template
boxes so you can change how they look in
your notebook uniformly you can go in
and change the stock by changing the
stuff on the style sheet you'll change
how these actually appear and so so here
we we can see this you know parses it
formats it it works as it should so
again what is a template box so a
template box here is some sort of box
structure it's a sort of it's a
low-level notebook structure it takes a
list of arguments you know the boxes and
we've got a tag and that tag if it's a
string it goes and looks up the sort of
the style information on the style sheet
and then it applies the the display
function which is a box function it
takes a list of boxes and it produces
another box from it and that's used to
do the display of what the template box
should actually look like okay I should
also mention template boxes can be
nested any levels here we see you know
it's using our new form for you know
binomials and genre P and everything and
so the next next trick is of course if
we
can write our own make boxes and make
expression rules at various times to
affect the the things we want to so for
instance this is the next exercise we've
got a commutator here so this here is
you know Q here and it has you know the
crate full form we want to write a make
boxes rule for my commutator to get back
to the the template box of my commutator
now I've got this display function here
so you can actually see what it's doing
you know I could change this here I can
put you know squiggly brackets here if I
wanted and change the display of how it
actually looks and works and evaluates
okay but of course we've got this
display function here I've got it
handily built into the style sheet you
could you could enter in your own but
right there is a my commutator style
which has got exactly that function so
what we can do is we can turn around and
just remove that and now we get the
particular form as as would expect okay
so your task now is to write a make
boxes rule we're coming close to the
sort of end of time here so I might just
go ahead and do this so what we want is
a make boxes role of a my commutator
should be what boxes in standard form
well we want to make this general of
course we know this now and we want
which box as well we want it to be these
boxes and of course we want to make that
further make boxes any common standard
form in the same way with the be excuse
and now we have that goes like that
and full farm do I have to yep and it
works as as it should you know plus R
squared
my computer yeah oh my god
I've got to take up it's got the tag box
the full form tag box around it that's
right
I'll just type it in again see plus my
commutator
right and it does it works as it should
ok so so that's that's the my commutator
said its template boxes so I'll just
mention and closing just before
questions just just a few things one in
your construction of your boxes you
sometimes want to be able to use base
styles so normally if I have a style box
just like you know something's italic
next to it and you type next to an
italic you get the italics and you don't
want that you know in other words if I
have you know some text and I make that
you know here italic and I move next to
the italic and I start typing I get
italic stuff and sometimes you don't
want that you and so it's the same with
style box the style boxes will escape
but sometimes we want to just have that
style associated directly on on that
like for instance this under script box
so here's this base style background
goes to gray level and so as I type next
to it I the style doesn't escape so you
you sometimes use that in which boxes
you'll you'll construct and you'll see
it around almost all boxes have BAE
styles the difference here is so I've
got the style box of this under script
box here and so when I take a look at
that I've got this this is the actual
format style box underneath and so when
I type next to a style box just like
italics it escapes when I take a look at
this one we have just an under script
box and so the base style is actually in
there so the style won't or an escape
and that that's the advantage of using
base styles so I won't go into it in too
much detail I'll mention now it were to
like like to address your previous point
there's this option called syntax form
if we take a look at it on the the help
there's a it's minimally documented here
but it will sort of say stuff and you
can change the precedence of the various
operators by wrapping the syntax form
option on your template box and you've
got it for tag boxes as well and I'll
mention as well that some of the
typesetting is context-sensitive
so we see point here it's not typeset
but graphics the point inside graphics
is is typeset to a point box okay
and one final irrelevant note the the
CSS model is actually very similar
maybe they copied us
I doubt it but the the box the base
styles the default base styles the image
margins frame margins they're quite
similar to the actual CSS model and so
it's it's interesting to note that
basically a lot of these tree sorts of
markup languages ours is one of them
HTML is another have adopted the same
sorts of things it's a it's a natural
form of representing the underlying
content okay so the conclusions for
making a template box notation as you
enter a structure in 2d typesetting you
copy those boxes you don't try and
invent them yourself you copy those
boxes fill in the various arguments with
with with the hash n to get a pure
function put that resolving style a
style sheet create a make boxes rule to
get the output to be correct and for
bonus points maybe create an input alias
for the notation and that's sort of
along the lines of exactly what we do
internally to create all of the various
bits all the extensions that Mathematica
has and so now you two can go forth and
create the same stuff that we do
internally and and extend Mathematica to
your own ends and desires right
questions
[Applause]